[Music]
have you watched every single episode
the loud house has to offer
if so you might have realized that this
amazing cartoon has its fair share of
animation mistakes only dedicated fans
would have noticed the following
animation shortcuts you won't believe
how obvious number one is first time of
the things hit that subscribe button and
more awesome videos will come your way
oh and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up now let's jump right into
the ten loud house animation mistakes we
should get going you guys want to hang
with us the mysterious ketchup incident
if there's one thing fans notice while
watching the city slickers episode it's
not whipping a ketchup stain off your
shirt looks to be a lot easier on TV
when Lincoln and Lori decide to drive to
the city together they leave thinking
that great times await them to their
great dismay things don't go exactly as
planned
it becomes painfully obvious that Ronnie
Ann is slightly embarrassed of Lincoln
so much so that she does everything she
can to get him to stop talking in front
of other people during one scene Ronnie
and resorts to squirting Lincoln with a
bunch of ketchup to prevent him from
telling the story problem is Lincoln
simply whips the ketchup off like it's
no big deal
since many of us know that ketchup will
leave a red streak on fabric we consider
this to be a mishap but this isn't the
only thing we've noticed if you take a
deeper look you might even notice that
some of the ketchup packages keep
disappearing and reappearing right in
front of our eyes now that's what we
call an animation mix up the watermelon
drop there's nothing worse than racing
home to eat a tasty snack only to find
out that a sibling has gobbled it up if
you're an only child consider yourself
lucky
especially since you'll never know the
pain of opening an empty pizza box that
once belonged to you since Lincoln has
ten sisters of his own it's safe to say
that he knows a thing or two about
disappointment in the episode a fridge
too far
Lincoln races home to find that his mac
and cheese bites have been eaten wanting
to make sure that this never happens
again
he decides to teach his sisters a lesson
Lincoln gets the bright idea to
booby-trap the fridge which basically
creates a vicious fridge war Louanne
eventually tries to steal his food and
gets a watermelon dropped on her foot
for the next
couple of scenes LuAnn is seen wobbling
around in crutches but after a few short
moments her foothills and she's back to
her old self
while it's normal for cartoons to heal
quickly we never expected to see LuAnn
heal in the same episode she was injured
in this animation mistake has definitely
given us a lot to think about the
magical eyelashes don't get us wrong we
love the loud house but we are here to
point out some obvious animation
mistakes after all one of the biggest
issues animators face is consistency
which is why it comes as no surprise
that many of the loud house characters
have been spotted with missing eyelashes
while the occasional eyelash mishap is
totally reasonable some of the following
mistakes don't make much sense in the
episode left in the dark we couldn't
help but notice that Linney's eyelashes
disappear when they feast their eyes on
the TV set as one of the first episodes
of the series this definitely set the
eyelash standards at an all-time low
after all many of the characters were
eventually spotted with missing
eyelashes as well
on another note Linney's eyelashes were
also missing during the episode Driving
Miss hazy while many of us figured that
she'd taken them off her bed they
reappeared seconds after the initial
mistake
for now we're let's believe that drawing
eyelashes are the least of the animators
worries especially when Lenny is
concerned autumn in April it's only
normal for mistakes to happen every once
in a while however when it comes to the
loud house it's safe to say that
animation mistakes occur in nearly every
episode despite all of this loud house
is a great cartoon and small mistakes
aren't going to turn us off from it any
time soon in the episode fandom pane we
take a closer look at Lucy loud this
sister enjoys the simple things in life
like watching her favorite show on her
lonesome problem is when you have ten
siblings being alone doesn't exist what
was once considered as her alone time
gets taken away from her when her
sisters Laurie and Lenny fall in love
with the same show instead of welcoming
her sisters with open arms
Lucy tries to convince them that the
show is rotten in order to never miss an
episode again the sisters run to the
calendar and start reserving the
timeslot for the following month during
this scene there are two things we
noticed first off the calendar clearly
says April despite the trees having red
and orange leaves on them sadly the
month
April has 35 days attached to it this
simply makes no sense but hey we're not
complaining please keep the episodes
coming where's the money when Luna
realizes that she's short on cash she
decides to ask around for some greens
unfortunately for her her siblings don't
seem to have any deep pockets to offer
her deciding to put her talents to the
test
Luna grabs her guitar and heads outside
she leaves her guitar case open on the
sidewalk to allow pedestrians to drop
their cash inside and well it works
before long Lunas guitar skills are
causing a pile of cash to appear in her
case however her neighbor ends up
sticking his head out of the window and
telling her that he'll pay her to stop
playing music which is something she
agrees to this scene may seem
straightforward but there's an animation
mistake at play Lena's guitar case was
stacked with bills before her neighbor
called out to her but afterwards there
was some money missing from it so did
Luna get robbed or did the animators
make a little mistake Lincoln's backpack
if there's one thing we've learned from
watching the loud house it's that family
is the most important thing of all not
only are your siblings always there for
you when you need them they're also
always there when you don't want them to
be as the only boy in his family Lincoln
may have been the only loud child to
have side stepped hand-me-downs since
big families can be expensive it's only
normal for parents to recycle their kids
clothing but when it comes to Lincoln
it's safe to assume that he's never had
to wear his siblings clothes or use
their accessories before huge loud house
fans definitely know what Lincoln's
everyday attire is after all it's quite
simple he likes to wear an orange shirt
jeans white sneakers and a blue backpack
for some odd reason however there was
one scene where he and Clyde were
walking to school together and Lincoln
was suddenly sporting a brown backpack
since this isn't normal in the slightest
many of us believe it to be an animation
mistake in the ends he wouldn't have
borrowed his sister's backpack for
school color mistakes when you have a
minimum of 13 cartoon characters per
episode it's only normal for you to
forget about the technicalities while it
may not be the biggest deal we've
noticed that some of the loud family's
attire has changed color over the course
of a few seconds since most cartoon
characters tend to wear the same outfit
over and over again we're a little
confused as to why this is happening
there's one animation mistake that keeps
coming back it's the color of Laurie
shoes
the oldest loud sister isn't one to
mismatch her outfit so we've come to the
conclusion that animators are taking
shortcuts
we're met by an annoyed family who is
tired of Laurie's power trip as the
oldest of the family she takes it upon
herself to manage her younger siblings
and not always in the nicest way in an
attempt to overthrow her rule the
younger loud siblings pull their energy
into one bunch and meet their sister
heaven they tie her to a chair and
restrict her every move in the scene
where Laurie is being carried around in
a chair we noticed that her shoes go
from baby blue to black since she was
tied up at the time there's no way she
could have switched them herself this
isn't the first time that's allowed
House animators mixed up their colors
and it probably won't be the last
where did the berries go going on a
family vacation is a whole lot of fun
however there's nothing fun about
meeting hiccups on the road when the
loud family decides that it's time for a
family vacation a good majority of its
members get jobs to help pay for the
upcoming trip since paying for a family
of 13 to go on vacation is extremely
expensive the Lao children make it a
point to contribute if there's one thing
we know about the loud family it's that
their van isn't exactly up to speed
throughout the series we've seen this
van go through many ups and downs
however selling it and replacing it with
something new has never been an option
for dear old dad during the episode
trips we see the loud family driving up
a steep hill since their van is slow an
old man in the pickup truck starts
honking at them wanting to drive at a
faster speed he eventually passes them
and speeds off when we first lay eyes on
the old trucker we see that he has
crates of strawberries in his trunk
however when we see in passing the van
the strawberries are completely gone
this animation mistake is very hard to
spot out which is maybe why the
animators thought it wasn't a big deal
to forget about the berries
Lincoln's chipped tooth since animation
mistakes don't hurt anyone most of us
would agree that they really aren't that
big of a deal however they can come off
looking like an eyesore to some very
attentive viewers when the Louds decide
that it's time for the family picture
Lincoln takes it upon himself to
organize the entire thing since most of
his siblings are refusing to put on a
pretty face and smile
he takes it upon himself to straighten
them out to do this he takes away all of
their props and forces them into
Christmas sweaters unfortunately for him
doing this proves to be extremely
difficult especially since his sisters
want nothing to do with the picture
after putting way too much effort in
capturing the perfect shots his sisters
decide to give the camera their best in
order to make the photo flawless Lincoln
makes everyone wear fake teeth for
perfections sake funny enough Lincoln
doesn't put any fake teeth on himself
and yet the final picture shows him with
a perfect smile since Lincoln's front
teeth are severely chipped
we couldn't help but notice this
animation mistake like we would a deer
in headlights just making around for my
weekly DNA keek swamp self playing
guitars it's no secret that loon aloud
is an incredibly gifted guitar player
however she has showed us on more than
one account that her guitar has a mind
of its own during the roadie to nowhere
episode we see Luna practicing for an
upcoming concert
she's super excited to show off her
skills in front of a huge crowd as she
should be
while most viewers won't pay much mind
to Lunas finger motions actual guitar
players just might throughout this
episode we see Luna flipping her guitar
in the air while managing to maintain
every single beat which is just
impossible sure this is a cartoon but
some things can't help but be pointed
out there are a few animation mistakes
that occur during this point one of them
being that Luna throws her hands up in
the air of rocking out the fact that her
guitars don't miss a beat is definitely
something to Marvel about have you ever
noticed any loud house animation
mistakes of your own if so don't
hesitate to let us know what they are in
the comments after all you might have
caught something that no one else has
ever noticed and that's it for 10 loud
house animation mistakes we hope you
enjoyed the video see you next time
[Music]